it's the liberal's worst nightmare from
a former president Donald Trump
participating in a CNN Town Hall where
he bashed Joe Biden clashed with the
moderator and even got cheers from the
audience
we had no inflation we had the lowest
Energy prices we've had in decades this
country was rocking and rolling if I'm
president I will have that War settled
in one day 24 hours what is the first
thing you would do to help bring down
the cost to make things more affordable
drill baby drill there's never been
anything like is happening to our
country you built about 52 miles
this is what she does
I built hundreds of miles you know who
took them more than anybody is Joe Biden
he has 1800 boxes and nobody even knows
and nobody talks about him Mr President
it's very simple to answer that's why I
asked it it's very simple that you're a
nasty person I'll tell you
despite the fact that Trump is leading
the Republican field Democrats in the
partisan press are completely losing
their minds at CNN forgiving the former
president a platform
I just don't really understand why they
didn't just cut him off but what I
didn't know was that the audience would
be filled with his cult
to know if CNN was passing out Kool-Aid
before the event started
I think it was a profoundly
irresponsible decision there is no sense
in fact checking or replaying the
highlights I'm sure you're going to have
more fact checks for us because there
were more lies than I could count I
think we needed a Chiron This Is A Lie
This Is A Lie This Is A Lie this is a
lie
and a republican lawmaker is taking a
shot at CNN as well for not being
interested in the issues that voters
care about
Town Halls are for the voters not for
the Press not for the person who's the
moderator Caitlyn spent more time
interjecting her own viewpoints or her
own look views on a situation those are
actually now are you are you guys not
going to interject do I get a chance
the Border fentanyl the debt ceiling
foreign policy
you know Dana what's interesting about
it is we just saw uh Byron Donalds the
congressman get interrupted by CNN on
that panel just the way uh Trump was
interrupted constantly when he was
trying to answer a question I mean it's
not only about the questions that were
asked but how they were being asked well
yeah I mean that's their choice right
like so but I think the thing that's
interesting to me that I've been
thinking about all day is that does CNN
or anybody else think that there is an
actual GOP Primary going on right now
or do they think that Donald Trump has
the nomination because what happened
last night was basically saying here is
the former president
he's it has a stage to himself he's he
has a friendly audience with a moderator
we know he goes out to the media and
people love it and the friend the
audience is going to love it so they're
going to go after her and all the things
that Republicans might talk about in
their primary debate like coveted
responses uh inflation taxes crime maybe
even gun control like none of that comes
up there's when I talk about all the
other things that you're going to talk
about in a general election so what they
basically did is to say there is no GOP
Primary and the GOP Primary candidates
of which there are several and some who
say they're going to announce soon
apparently do they think there's a GOP
Primary because they don't say anything
about Donald Trump either so unless
you're basically going to have someone
like DeSantis come out and say okay I'll
take him on here's what you have you're
not going to the the Democrats are not
going to win against Trump by having
Caitlyn Collins ask him the questions if
you want to actually see Donald Trump
have an argument you might have had
Vivek ramaswamy on as well or Nikki
Haley or somebody else like that because
it's like I feel like we have just
jumped ahead like there is no GOP
Primary and it could turn out that there
might not be one at all I just think
that that part is weird and also for all
the Liberals complaining that CNN held
this town hall with Donald Trump I am
sure that CNN would love to have Joe
Biden come up and do a town hall in fact
we could schedule that for next
Wednesday yeah Jesse what do you think
the chances are of Joe Biden doing his
CNN town hall and what about the fact
also that that Caitlin Collins did you
know the traditional Democrat you know
January 6 Georgia all of the things that
we know that they're interested in but
that the public really isn't interested
in and saying address suggestions your
first question Joe will eventually do a
town hall and it will be boring and they
will not interrupt or fact check him
once even though he'll lie constantly
your other question is Caitlyn Dana is
right this is the perfect format for
Donald Trump you're going to put
president Trump live in the middle of a
little Arena surrounded by fans up
against a 30 year old CNN anchor
oh my God I mean that was not fair last
night that's what everybody wants to see
and so CNN I think did well though
because CNN's making a business decision
here they're going to Pivot and say
we're going to play in this political
game in the primary maybe and we're
going to chase ratings they got a good
number last night and we're going to try
to be normal again like we used to now
the rest of the media is hysterical
because their strategy was to censure
and scandalize the president don't let
them talk ignore him and treat him like
a disease now the media only works in a
mob and if CNN breaks then Trump just
broke them and CNM helped them break it
Trump was good just by showing up
Trump's been out in the wilderness for a
while and now he's coming back to the
mainstream media he's re-entered he's
becoming more commercially viable and
that's what he's wanted and when he
started off really calm and relaxed that
was smart they wanted them go out there
thrashing around and he didn't but he
built up a crescendo and then at the end
he called her nasty and that was the
best part he loves conflict
the media hates conflict because the
media wants 100 percent agreement so
Trump and the media don't mix and
they're going to have to wrap their
heads around this because he is going to
be appearing on some of their programs
and the way they conducted that did not
work for them and that's why the media
is so scared because they see how
powerful he is once he gets his message
out you know Jessica the truth is that
CNN knew that that Donald Trump would be
saying things that they didn't agree
with I mean obviously but they made a
business decision and they got a they
got a viewership of what we get every
day they got three million viewership
um and and yet people are saying they
should have cut them off and and they
should have turned that off they should
say that's a lie I mean where do you
stand on this
um I stand on the part that feels like
we're stuck between a rock and a hard
place which everyone has been with
Donald Trump since he came down the gold
staircase
you can't ignore him he's likely to be
the GOP nominee again he ended up the
president United States of America and
was the candidate in 2020. so you do
have a responsibility I think as news
people to talk about what's going on in
one of the two major political parties
I can only imagine though that Donald
Trump orchestrated every single second
of how that town hall played out that he
was able to get a completely friendly
audience there on a college campus
Republican primary candidates
Republican primary voters right they
didn't even have an undecided voter
though they didn't throw in an
independent or someone who said I voted
for you in 2016 but I didn't in 2020
because of XYZ reason how are you going
to win back my vote it was a fan boy and
girl session the entire time which does
benefit him to the point about the fact
checking I I think that it is important
to make sure that people at least hear
some pushback whether they actually
process what it is that you said in
response
that the truth does have to get out
there and there was such an incredible
Cascade of Lies flowing out of his mouth
from the border wall he said you know I
I secured the whole thing it's 1900
miles long he did 52 new miles the
documents Obama took documents didn't
happen Joe Biden didn't comply Joe Biden
did comply perfect phone calls with Brad
raffensberger and with zelenski that
Democrats support infanticide and
Caitlyn Collins let that one go and I
thought that was a major losing moment
for her because if you want to make the
jobs decision a focal point which it
absolutely will be in this election and
you hear the former presidents say the
Democrats support abortion up till nine
months even after the baby's born
complete dereliction of Duty and on the
day after he gets a ruling that he's
sexually abused and defamed E.G Terrell
and he calls her a whack job and the
audience is laughing it was a just
appalling and I think that's what a lot
of the commentators were on afterwards
were were reflecting on but you're the
network that fired Don Lemon for
misogyny and then you have Don Donald
Trump up there going after a victim of
his in such a way they asked the
question you're now arguing against
yourself you're saying how good it was
that they had him on and then you're
shocked that Donald Trump I started with
you're between a rock and a hard place
and that is the truth I think that he
needs to be heard but also it is
repellent to listen to if he was asked
about an accusation of rape that they
said didn't happen but he has every
reason to respond he was accused of
defamation for saying he didn't do it
and then they asked him about it and he
did it again
like and like this is like going to see
a John Wick Sequel and complaining about
the gunfire it's like going to the Opera
Opera why is there so much singing how
do these naked women get into this strip
club so this is the problem with this
media meltdown right it's like I I I get
it CNN is bad for your health if you're
a liberal because they they force you to
relive a problem rather than move past
it right they never act they never
talked about the future like you said
they just went back and back back so
every liberal has to sit there it's like
it's like they have to relive something
that happened in their past that they
don't want to Meanwhile for people like
me it's awesome it is so much fun and
you know that it's great for my mental
health because nothing is more
entertaining than watching Trump speak
and Caitlyn underspeak it was like it
was greater than watching the CNN panel
it was so funny it's like a new breed of
urban Miserables you know all
makes all complaints universe
University perennial
s though none of this ever happened
before this is all new right God I
missed him and I gotta say one thing
else
he showed you one thing that that is
really important he hasn't aged Biden
Biden is aging he's aging like a sliced
Apple in the Sun and here and it's like
it's like
you notice that Stephanie rule is about
a third his age or half his age right I
don't know 30 to 70. I can't do the math
yeah Caitlyn what did I say Stephanie
rule who interviewed yeah yeah Caitlyn
Caitlyn yeah but he was a rabbit she was
a slug meanwhile Joe needed Stephanie
rule to spoon feed him the questions and
the answer like his morning Maalox I
mean imagine if they put Biden in that
kind of interrogation how hilarious that
would be but right we got to go back the
media either has learned nothing
which might be contagious or they have
or they are doing this on purpose which
is not fair to Jessica because what I'm
saying is Jessica has been made you
upset we could we should have watched
this together yeah we would have had so
much fun oh yeah instead you watched him
I'm sure he's gonna be asking for
another one so we can do that come to
Fox
oh you ain't trying Trump yeah I'm here
to come all right hi winner Brian
Kilmeade I want you to do me a favor I
want you to click to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page this is the only
way that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on Fox you can get it
all here on YouTube so subscribe right
now